alrighty everybody our friend ami
horowitz he has another man on the
street video i can't wait to see what he
did this time this video is sponsored by
expressvpn i'm mommy horowitz and i'm
here in woketown usa to ask people why
they think there's a higher level of
obesity in the black community
everything has to do with racism racism
i would call it institutional racism
eating could be a coping mechanism
for racism yeah if they feel bad it's
like depression based so maybe the
stress of
racism maybe does contribute and black
people deal with racism every day and
that leads to bad food choices oh god
absolutely
okay so you'll notice that all the white
people are like yes the black people are
eating bad food because the black people
are experiencing racism in american
society now if you ask them
why white people are very fat because
there are a lot of fat white people they
would say it's personal choice right
it's all the white people who are eating
bad stuff because they're dumb hicks
these are all upper class white liberals
so they'd be saying oh you know the only
fat people that i know are those hicks
from the sticks so probably it's because
they're stupid making bad food choices
because they're white but if it's people
of color then it's well it must be not
that they are making personal choices
that impact their diet it must be
because of widespread institutional
racism i wonder if black people feel the
same way as white people i have a
feeling the answer is no just as
upper-class white liberals think that
police are the worst thing for black
communities and black people like nah we
kind of need the cops i have a feeling
that if ami asks a bunch of black people
the same question their answers are not
going to resemble the answers given by
these upper crust white liberals
education is a factor as well um which
also tries them to erase it you know
like racism they're not being educated
as to what is good to eat what is not
good to eat yeah oh they're ignorant
they're ignorant and that's it yeah so
this lady thinks that it's cause black
people are stupid or something it's not
racist though when she says that they're
too stupid to eat healthy food that's
not racist she's anti-racist probably
then you're not gonna be able to choose
the right things for you especially if
you don't know about them too there's a
lot more in-depth stuff that
predominantly like a lot of white people
are more in tune with i don't know how
to be healthy see i got some weed i'm
trying to roll up you stopped me at a
bad time yeah no problem if you say
individual responsibility
is that
coming from a white privilege and white
supremacy
100 yeah they don't have any access to
good okay i'm sorry this is yeah so it's
all these white people they don't have
any access to good food meanwhile that
lady's gonna go trot over to whole foods
the baseline notion here that black
people don't know what is healthy is
kind of crazy it's kind of crazy and
it's kind of racist like i have small
children and even they know what is
healthy to eat and what is not healthy
to eat i'm pretty sure that black people
know what is healthy to eat and what is
not healthy to eat yeah like you know
there's more mcdonald's there's all
their supermarkets it's all like doritos
and everything et cetera et cetera do
you think it's possible that court of
america would look and destroy the black
community and therefore put a lot of the
stuff in there um i think um definitely
under some administrations for sure okay
so under some administrations i love
that trump probably put the mcdonald's
in the black community so here's the
problem they've tried to put place
things like whole foods in black
communities and it turns out that the
market just doesn't exist for it a lot
of people just don't want to buy stuff
from there it is true that healthy food
is sometimes more expensive than
unhealthy food but it depends on the
kind of healthy food that you're talking
about right manufactured garbage yeah
stuff that is just like heavily greased
up french fries in a burger that could
be pretty cheap but the truth is that it
can appease is also pretty cheap okay so
you can find healthy food at a low price
the notion that it is just a price
differential that explains all of this
is not true there's a lot of personal
decision making that is happening right
here and if you think that whole foods
would avoid being in a black area if
there are a lot of people who want to
buy organic kale from whole foods no
corporations are pretty profit driven do
you think it's a conscious decision by
corporate america to destroy the black
community by making sure they have all
these unhealthy choices yeah i think
it's possible it could be good
where trader joes are we're like just
bougie grocery stores are they're all in
white neighborhoods all of them yeah
like there's no whole foods there
we're here in the heart of harlem to
find out if what we just heard is true
[Music]
uh-oh
so yeah there's a whole foods right in
the middle of harlem
whoops we'll get some more on this in
just one second first how did you choose
which internet provider to use the sad
thing is most of us really don't have
much choice because isps do operate like
monopolies in the regions they serve and
then use that monopoly power to take
advantage of their customers data caps
streaming throttles the list goes on and
on worst of all many isps log your
internet activity and then sell that
data on to other big tech companies or
advertisers to prevent isps from seeing
my internet activity i protect all my
devices with expressvpn so what is
expressvpn it's a simple app for your
computer or smartphone it encrypts all
your network data tunnels it through a
secure vpn server so your isp can't see
any of your activity think about how
much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit every video
you watch every message you send it gets
tracked by isps or other tech giants who
can sell that information for profit
that's the reason i recommend expressvpn
is the best way to hide your online
activity from your isp you download the
app you tap one button on the device and
you are now protected i mean look how
easy i just go over here i access that
expressvpn app right now it says not
connected but
doink
now it's connected and now all of my
internet activity is private expressvpn
does all of this without slowing your
connection that's why it's rated the
number one vpn service by both cnet and
wired so stop handing over your personal
data to isps and other tech giants who
mine your activity and sell off your
information protect yourself with the
vpni trust to keep me private online
visit expressvpn.com
get three extra months for free
is the obesity rate in the black
community because of racism i think it's
because of probably what they eat
i have a choice i just think people need
to watch their eating habits it's also
down to you know the individual and the
household and what they learn from the
family around them what they see around
them as well it's like saying we don't
know what we're doing half the time
we're making the choices we make
and some in many instances knowing the
consequences in the long run okay by the
way this guy for president right here in
fact all of these people for president
all the people that omni is talking to
who are like yeah you know you got to
make good individual choices if you
don't want to be fat this is why upper
crust white progressives cannot run the
country they are terrible for the
country they are terrible for black
people they are terrible for white
people they are terrible for everything
people eat food and they like different
food some people like that being on a
diet some people like rhonda some people
don't individual choices they said to me
that saying that about black people is
racist it's like saying black people
don't have free will black people don't
have agency exactly like that isn't that
racist that's a little bit to me yes
it's very weird to hear me personally
yeah that guy that guy's great i'm a fan
slot open a daily wire for that guy
whenever he wants it they deal with
racism so often the day that they stress
eat
what
does that sound right to
i love you reaction
it's all these white people like black
people are so stressed they just have to
sit home and eat cheetos because they're
so stressed this lady's like what are
you talking about what huh
yeah
the wokes man
no one likes them now if they put a big
hamburger place and you keep going to it
and you gain weight they didn't make you
go in there that's what i'm looking at
whose fault is that that's the person
that's going in there are you blaming
this guy that opened in his business i'm
fat mad it's bad does one do you carry
it well thank you appreciate that
i like that lady she's like yeah i'm
just going to own it you know what my
decisions are my own i like how i look
feel good for her i took the ownership
of my weight and my weight gained so you
have to take ownership of your own
health you know what
y'all are doing some good stuff and
hauling i'm not a razor no it's not no
this is there's plenty of fat everywhere
so again you'll notice that for the
wokes they're not solutions oriented
nothing they do makes anybody's life
better shouting about how whole foods is
racist and how about corporations
because of trump are locating in black
areas is helping no one you know what
helps people telling them that they
ought to get control over their own
weight it is hard to think of anything
that is more personal to you than your
eating habits you literally make that
decision multiple times a day i make
that decision too i try to keep myself
in good shape i work out a lot but i'm
disappointed in myself sometimes because
i make bad dietary choices i mean
literally yesterday i started off the
day i had a coffee i had like one egg
and i was like i'm doing great and then
lunch came i went out to lunch with my
wife and just blew it out with the carbs
that's my fault okay and that's true for
everyone there is no more personal
decision over which you have more choice
in the united states than the kind of
food that you eat and trying to blame it
on systemic racism or systemic poverty
is really really dumb you do have to ask
the question as to why white wolf
progressives think that they can speak
for black people this way and the answer
really does go to something that shelby
steele talked about a long time ago
which is that white progressives want to
maintain control of the conversation
it's really about power for them if they
get to say that racism not my racism
systemic racism everybody else's racism
is the problem and then they can say
that black people have no responsibility
inside the system then it is not up to
black people to fix their lives and it's
not even up to black people to fix the
system it's up to white woke liberals to
fix the system so they get to maintain
the power by dissociating from all of
these white institutions and then
correcting them from the outside so all
these people are really claiming power
it's not about them being humble about
their own race or about their impact on
the world it is about them dissociating
from all these other bad institutions
demonstrating their own
moral
credit and credibility and then being
able to say i want to control the system
in order to fix it that really is what
it's about enjoyed reviewing ami's
latest video can't wait to see what he
does next cause he's crazy
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video